you lose your sight and everything gets
a little harder everything takes longer
the walls seem to be caving in on you
all the time
when I was introduced to blind sailing
it was really an opportunity for me to
push the walls out to feel reconnected
with the earth
my name is wall Ranieri I'm the skipper
of blind match racing team USA won for
that blind met Racing World
Championships here in Sheboygan
Wisconsin for myself as a visually
impaired individual I'm looking forward
to putting a lot of the stuff I've been
thinking about for the last couple
months into practice you hold in and
I'll kick off
tell me win when we're racing there's no
sighted people on the boat it's just the
three blind crewmembers you're relying
on other members of the crew literally
for your life it doesn't take long for
that bond to develop
there's three buoys in blind Matt
tracing each of those buoys makes a
distinct sound we listen for where the
buoys are on the water and we navigate
using mental triangulation and by basis
of where we are in relation to those
buoys we know where we are in the water
there are many times where the boats are
coming right out one another and we need
to know where they are they need to know
where we are the reach of the boats has
a sound emitted vision is by far a human
beings predominant sense but you take
away the vision the audio sense picks up
real quick there you go
pressure is feeling better now at times
it feels like a little bit of controlled
chaos the truth of it is with with a
good team and Joe everything is under
control as chaotic as it may look about
12 years ago now just about I lost 95%
of my vision in about five months I had
a very very tough period of time until
one day I figured out how to stop being
a poorly functioning sighted person and
start being a highly functioning blind
person and then began doing things that
I'd never done before I lost my sight
including sailing for anyone who thinks
that they can't do something it's too
hard it's too complicated it's too
frustrating I'm here to tell you that's
just not true add a little courage and
you can do just about anything